شابه سعوديه تحولت اسمها الى تراند على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي والسبب الشبه
الكبير الذي لاحظه الجمهور بينها وبين
جورجينا رودريغيز صديقه النجم كريستيانو
رونالدو القصه بدات بعد نشرها مقطع فيديو
وهي تقلد اطلاله عارضه الازياء
الارجنتينيه التي ارتدتها اثناء استقبال
كريستيانو في الملعب فريق النصر ظهرت شابه
داخل سياره مرتديا نفس اطلاله جورجينا
والميك اب ايضا كما انها قلدت عباره
كريستيانو التي القتها باللغه العربيه
اثناء ترحيبها على جماهير نادي النصر
السعودي الفيديو اثار تفاعل عدد كبير من
رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي كما حافظ
على اعجاب الكثيرين لتقارب الشبح بين
الفتاه وبين صديقه رونالدو
[موسيقى]
من الجمال تنضم لنا شبيهه جورجينا صديقه
اللاعب العالمين كريستيانو رونالدو وريم
العنزي ريم يسعد صباحك اهلا بك معنا بصبح
العربيه
في فيلم سعودي مؤخرا هل تشبهك بجورجينا
رودريغيز هو جزء من هذا التمثيل
بس انه تركتر اللي طلعت فيك شبيهه جورجينا
انه جزء يعني
بس يعني مو نفس الشخصيه
السعيده
الناس وقفتك على اساس انك جورجينا
ايوه من بعد انتشار تداول الفيديو في كثير
حتى يعني قبل يومين كان عندي لقاءات
تلفزيوني في كثير يعني حتى الكاميرات انه
في ناس يمرون رونالدو يتكلمون رونالدو اه
كثير حسابك الاشياء طب ريم كيف شهادتي
تفاعل الجمهور وخصوصا السعودي معك على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بسبب هذا الشبه
كيف تلاقيتي التفاعل
والله كانت تفاعل كبير مو متوقع اساسا
الفيديو ما توقعت ان انت تشرف خلال ساعتين
بس انه كان في تفاعل انه في ناس همم
تقول هذه مو شخصيتك بس يعني ما في احد
مستحيل احد يطلع بدون انتقادات
والله برايك الواحد خاص يعني اكيد انا ما
احب اقارن بينهم مين احلى ومين اجمل طيب
ريم انت ظهرتي في فيديو على التيك توك مع
شبيه اللاعب العالمي كريستيانو رونالدو
حديثين عن قصه هذا الفيديو
كريستيانو
ابل ولا فقط بعد انتقال كريستيانو رونالدو
لكي الموجهه لك على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي
بصراحه والله ما اقراها الكومنتات يعني
اذا في كومنتات على طول اطلع ولا اهتم لها
لانه
الناس متكلمين متكلمين كل الاحوال صابرين
مين اول من لفت نظرك للشبه بينكم
وفجاه كنت اسولف مع الجمهور اللي باللايك
زاد عدد اللايف فجاه انه كلهم فكر لك جورج
دخلنا نحسب نظاره